[Music]
Brother, how you doing? UK.
>> People don't People don't know that me
and you went to school together,
>> bro. We went to school. We went to
secondary school together, bro.
>> Unbelievable. I remember the same kind
of area as well in London.
>> Literally same same basically in the
same area.
>> Same area.
>> Yeah. Same area. Yeah. So,
>> let's I think that's a good place to
start.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz you I think you're about 3 years
older than me. I was in year seven. You
were in year 10.
>> Yeah. There about right. How old are you
now? 36.
>> 38.
>> Oh, is it? So, you must have been much
older. Yeah.
>> Um,
>> do you remember there was a few figures
there? There was a few like names people
were very scared of. Were you Were you
in Tundai's year?
>> Tundday. Tundday.
>> Was he one year before?
>> He's one year below.
>> Yeah. Yeah. People scared of this.
>> The thing is we we had we had many
characters that came from Winston
Kinston. Yeah,
>> there's there's been weird enough a lot
of success and then a lot of crazy
stories as well.
>> But yeah, our school was interesting. It
was
>> to be honest. Yeah, it was very
interesting. But that's a good place to
start because a lot of people in the
school went into sorry to say a life of
crime obviously deprived backgrounds,
disenfranchised backgrounds etc. A lot
of them got into education and then
you've got someone like yourself who's
obviously made a star of themselves.
Yeah. Alhamdulillah. I'm always in one.
So martial arts as a vocation or as a
hobby or as some kind of an activity for
someone who is young.
>> Yeah.
>> Who could go into a you know a life of
crime. What do you think of that?
>> So I I always say the the one thing that
martial arts gave me was a second peer
group.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now, regardless of where we
come from, you know, as you say, people
come from underprivileged backgrounds
and so on and so forth, it makes it
easier to kind of just be bought on that
first peer group that you find, first
friendship group that you find, anything
that you always want to impress them and
so on and so forth.
>> I had the ability to say no to these
people
>> simply because I was like, "Yeah, but
these guys would actually beat me up."
Yes,
>> and they were also my peer group is
people that I spent a lot of time with,
trained with, traveled with. I I look at
them as my older brothers, older
siblings, older sisters, and I didn't I
prefer to disappoint these guys here
than I would disappoint, you know, this
new peer group that I've I've found in
martial arts. It's right. I think
martial arts, I don't care what art it
is. I think it just teaches you so many
different things and everybody from all
ages should be involved in that.
>> Yeah. I mean, um, we talked about Allst
Star Boxing Globe, which is close to
your house as well. I saw a lot of
people from the streets. I I went there
as well when I was younger. I saw a lot
of people from the streets coming out of
the streets and into that. And now it's
just like directing their energies into
that. And I think it really is a good
way because thing is with with the
youth, we've got a lot of crime, a lot
of stuff going on,
>> but we don't give them alternatives.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're saying it's a very very good
alternative.
>> It's a it's it's one of the best
alternatives. It it teaches you
discipline. And it teaches you
self-control. It teaches you um you know
even just people skills cuz you spend a
lot of time with so many you get so many
walks of life that end up in a gym.
>> There's people that I'm friends with now
that like close friends with that live
in Liverpool that live in Italy that
live in I would never have come across
these people had it not been for martial
arts.
>> You see what I'm saying? So
>> how did you start? What was the the
first thing you did? You did kickboxing
in the beginning.
>> So I did Laar Kung Fu.
>> Okay. But the competitions that we did
was kickboxing competitions.
>> And there's lots of clips on you like of
you online doing knocking people out. So
it's the same kind of style though from
when you were young until now.
>> Yeah. Same style. The it's a different
rule set. The rules are is more I'd
always say it leans towards taekwondo.
It's more point scoring. Now, the reason
why my style is as as effective as it is
now is because when we was uh when I was
doing the the kickboxing, the element
that we focus on is the speed element,
getting in and getting out without being
touched because we having to score
points. Whereas a lot of other
kickboxing arts, nothing is better, but
it's just different. A lot of other
kickboxing arts focus on the KO and
focus on the power. Now, the reason why
my movement is so slick and fast and and
hard to read is because I didn't focus
on the power. I know that speed kills
and you can with speed comes power and
the sport focuses on the speed.
>> Yours is very in and out of style and
you're jumping all the time. It's like
that you need to train yourself cuz I
tried doing it myself.
>> I tried I got exhausted and this is a
lot this style.
>> It's it's funny you say that. Um, for
those that watch boxing, Yeah. Derek
Chazora actually trains in our gym as
well.
>> Oh, is it?
>> Yeah. And, um,
>> I saw him doing some grappling and stuff
as well.
>> Yeah. He was again, he was having fun,
you know. He he he spoke about Yeah.
wanting to do an MMA fight a while ago
>> and one of my teammates, uh, he's like,
I want to feel that leg kick. I want to
feel that leg. Want to feel what it
feels like.
>> Yeah.
>> He took one leg kick and changed his
direction back to boxer.
>> He said, okay, okay. I know.
>> You know, when I was young, I think I
might have been 18 or 19 years old. I
thought there is he doesn't know this.
He doesn't know who I am.
>> I was I was trying to park my car.
>> Yeah. And then he was he was there and I
was I didn't know it was him.
>> I I knew who he was by it was him.
>> And so I was trying to park my car and
then um I was like, "Who's this idiot
that's not who's this idiot that's not
letting me park my car?" I looked out
the window. I saw Derek Chisora. I just
went like this.
>> Please, please go. My car doesn't fit
anywhere. It's fine. I think you lived
in Finchley Road or something like that.
He has been around there. Yeah. Yeah. I
wrote like Milh Hill now or something.
So yeah, kind of.
>> So you train with a lot of boxers as
well then?
>> Yeah, we had it. The thing is cuz it's
mixed martial arts. What we try to do is
we'll bring in the top jiu-jitsu guy and
I have to go against it. Now it's it's
your area. I'm It's not for me. It's my
goal is to try and beat you, but the
likeliness is I'm not going to beat you.
But it teaches me a lot
>> and it shows me where I am in my
jiu-jitsu. Then I get a top wrestler and
the same again. But I always say the one
of the first things that you're going to
be doing is punching.
>> Like the second we start, we both start
on our feet. We don't start on the
floor. You know what I mean? We don't
start clinched.
>> You start you're probably most likely
going to be boxing or kicking.
>> So you have to be good at at boxing. So
>> people that we both know when they say
your grapple is actually very good. You
got very tight grip. I think your
grappling is underrated, would you say?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is. You know, it's it's
just something I love to do.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh like in the gym. I go to other
grappling gyms and and and like you know
I enjoy the grappler element of it but
when it comes to the showman in me
>> and what I'm best at I don't care to
grapple and again so it's definitely not
like it's definitely not my best thing
it's not my best weapon.
>> Yeah
>> and this is why but I enjoy it and I
keep trying to wrestling competition.
>> I did a grappling competition.
>> Yeah. It's a big show. It's a big show
and I won that one as well. Yeah. But
again for me um
>> that is really impressive though
background to something completely
different.
>> I love to challenge myself all the time
and I always say I'm forever a student.
It doesn't matter how successful I
become. I will I'll always go to
somebody's gym and seek information. I'm
not going to go there thinking that I
know it all. I'm going there to find out
what I've missed, you know, what I can
pick up.
>> So yeah, challenging myself all the time
and I think for everybody is important
to do. We we love to sit in our comfort
zones a lot. So, it's important to to
challenge yourself.
>> Well, talking about that, I mean, you
were first in Bellator and then you
moved to the UFC and that's the that's
the big story now that you moved to the
UFC.
>> How do you compare the two? How do you
compare the competition in Bellator
versus the competition in the UFC?
>> You know what it's I would personally
say it's the same as in when it when you
get to the top end of MMA, everyone's
amazing. Everyone's super talented.
>> The the difference is the magnitude of
the event itself.
>> Is that what it is? It's very very
different. And I even for me, I'm
usually very relaxed under lights,
crowds. Yeah. And I'm I'm chill and I'
I've been accustomed to being on big
shows and so on and so forth. But when I
got to the UFC, even for me, I was like,
"Wow." Okay. It's it's very
>> Is it just the number of people in the
stadium?
>> It's the number of people, but it's the
energy that people bring. It's the the
almost the passion. It's the uh
expectation. Every there's there's so
much more weight carry to carry in the
UFC.
>> Stakes are much higher.
>> Yeah. the stakes are much higher and
obviously especially for myself I
managed to create quite a good
reputation just being from Bellator but
everyone that question mark was always
yeah but can he do that in the yeah but
can he do that in the UFC against this
guy that guy
>> but we saw in the last fight you can do
it
>> I mean we thought that he would start
wrestling you because he's from Dagistan
is
>> yeah yeah but he he likes to strike as
well and we kind of knew it was a it was
a good matchup the likeliness is he's
going to want to
>> his style is Your style was just like
kryptonite for his style.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But again, like I said,
because of my style is was based on the
speed element, the movement element, a
lot of people find it difficult.
>> He wasn't custom. He doesn't can't find
someone. You can't find someone in the
gym too. But the only other person is
like uh for those that watch Steven
Wonderboy Thompson comes from a very
similar background to myself and cuz
we're friends. Uh he's had people come
up to him like I want to, you know, I'm
fighting Michael. I like to fight. He's
like, "Nope, he's my friend. I want him
to win."
So you're not going to get any sparring
anywhere that can replicate who I am and
what style I'm going to be.
>> You'll have to go to like taekwondo art.
>> Yeah. But even that, like I said, we
lean into taekwondo, but we're not quite
taekwondo. So there are slight
differences and you wouldn't really
notice it. It looks quite similar. So
you wouldn't really notice it. So you
I've seen guys have taekwondo guys and
I'm I'm laughing. I'm sitting there
laughing watching them train with
taekwondo guys knowing that it's not
going to be the same when I get in
there.
>> Cuz what you do is you establish a
rhythm right at the beginning and then
it's like you don't know when this guy's
going to pout. the person is just like
completely shocked by it all.
>> It's funny. I I I personally I call it
attaching strings. So a lot of the times
when you see me fight initially, you see
me doing a lot of fake movements. And
every time I fake, I see a response and
I'm like, "Okay, that leads to that." Or
fake, I see a response. Okay, that leads
to that. I might land a punch. I see
where you twitch, that leads to that.
Once I've attached as many strings, I'm
like, I'm basically, you know, I'm the
puppeteer. You're the puppet. I am
moving you around
>> and I know where you're going to end up,
where you're going to go. And then I can
create what I call a car crash effect. I
force you to come forward and I get
there quicker and create that collision
which is why like I said the speed
>> a backfooted fighter like someone who
doesn't like to go forward at all.
>> So yeah, you get that that just brings
different opportunities. The thing is
regardless your target is still to hit
me.
>> So even if you're going backwards,
there's still going to be certain things
you do to attack me at some. And I and
now for me to figure out it usually
takes a little bit longer when I have
somebody a bit more defensive or a bit
more of a counter fighter, but I get
there as well.
>> Who you trained with Hamzat as well?
He's he's in your division now, isn't
it? Yes.
>> Would you say you're more of a
welterweight or more of a middleweight?
>> Definitely more of a a welterweight.
Although everyone even people today,
they're like, "Man, you're bigger than I
expected." Um I I I'm very tall for that
division.
>> You're 6' three.
>> Yeah. Is that right?
>> So, but I'm very tall for the division.
>> Yeah. But in terms of stature, you see a
lot of people there. You just see the
difference when you're in the MMA. You
see the people's ankles are bigger. Like
wrist like that DDP looks like
heavyweight.
>> It's ridiculous. Yeah. Like his body
shape is just different. So he's
naturally more a middleweight. Yeah.
>> Whereas I'm naturally more a
welterweight.
>> And so you got people like DDP and
Hamzat. Who do you reckon is going to
win in that?
>> Man, that one.
>> I would love to.
>> You trained with Hamzat as well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you know what? Seeing
some I always say seeing somebody as spe
that special in person when they're
training
>> it's a it's a beautiful thing to watch
and it just inspires me more cuz he's
exceptional in a completely different
area to me.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I mean? I'm very good in
my area that
>> as well when you were training with
>> 100% and and you know there's certain
people that demand the room.
>> Yeah.
>> He walks in and he demands the room.
>> You know everyone he he's just you can
tell he's a superstar.
>> Yeah. but he's so good in his area and
just watching it I was just like yeah
it's it's unbelievable. I appreciate
like I said it just it makes me it
inspires me to go and
>> you know push myself more but saying
that in terms of coming to the fight DDP
is somebody that is the complete
opposite. I don't get how he keeps
winning as in I he does he's not a
person I look at and think oh man super
talented and obviously there's something
about him cuz he keeps winning and
sometimes even that is an art knowing
how to win. Do you reckon it's
psychological that he's got tremendous
will?
>> He has to be well trained obviously and
he does do things but he just seems
messy to me. But at the same time, you
have to give him his flowers. You have
to give him his respect because he's
still winning. And this is what that
every time I put myself money against
him, shall I say?
>> Yeah.
>> He he always comes up on top. So it's
just I would say I would normally say
Hamza would win this fight.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's just hard to say, man. just a
person that decided this very very
exceptional fight and I'm I'm going to
be there live and flesh cuz I'm fighting
that night as well
>> in
>> I wanted to ask you
>> um Islam Makf versus Tapora that's
another big one that people are talking
about who would you say who would you
>> uh I'd have to so Tapora is something
special as we've all seen he is
definitely something special very unique
I've been watching and studying a lot of
his training and how he's is this
mentality
>> he's ultra
>> confident Ultra confident.
>> We were celebrating one day before.
>> Ultra confident. But you have to be
that. You need that in this game. You
need that in this game. But I'd have to
say
Islam is just again something special
and the heavier guy, the naturally
heavier guy. So I have to give it when
when everything's even, you have to give
it to the person that's probably going
to bring more power.
>> Yeah. Because I was I was watching an
interview with Surukin and he was saying
that if you he was saying that if you
watch his if you watch the Porier's um
fight with Bryce Mitchell.
>> Yes.
>> The first round Bryce Mitchell had him
down with like a half guard position or
something like that. And so he said if
Bryce Mitchell can do that imagine what
>> exactly and that's again. Yeah.
>> Obviously Bryce Mitchell was very
aggressive in that area. Uh, I knew
Seapori would probably overcome that,
but somebody that's heavier, stronger,
landing a bit heavier punches and can
probably and and it for me is definitely
better than Barry Mitch.
>> Yeah.
>> It's Yeah. You have to kind of lean in
that in that direction.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you've got a fight coming up.
>> Yes.
>> And
>> he's been he's he's had kind of like a
mixed record. He's he's lost and won and
whatever, but he's a very strong and
competent.
>> Very strong. Remember, he used to be a
heavyweight. He's was a heavyweight
first. He's come down to light
heavyweight. Um he's now a middleweight.
I've gone up to middleweight. So he's
definitely going to be as we're talking
about power. He's definitely going to be
the the stronger person in certain
certain positions. But again, I always
my style and my speed, my timing is
always what I'm I'm going to favor cuz
>> youard grapple you.
>> I think everybody does. I think even
even the guys that say to themselves
that I'm the best striker in the world
and this and that, when they stand in
front of me, I'm just frustrating. It's
like trying to swat a fly. It's like
>> can't get there. So, you know, you end
up changing tactics and so many people
end up doing the same thing.
>> And his grappling is not like the
grappling of Hamza at all.
>> No, no, he's strong though and and I've
seen even he's he's for everybody. He's
for Izzy. He's for Marvin Vtori. He's
for Whitaker, like he's everybody. Um,
and you can see he's he's taken some of
these guys down. So, he has that
ability, but he's not really going to
grapple me. He's not really going to
which makes it more of exciting fight.
It's going to be he was the answer to to
>> cuz he's more of a he striker.
Definitely. He's going to want to try
that and he's everyone's going to start
everyone's going to start on plan A
until it doesn't work. So,
>> so people want to know about your
conversion.
>> Yeah.
>> People want to know what happened, what
triggered it, what
>> what did you how did you research it,
etc., etc. So, what's the story behind
that? So for me, I'd say over the last
six years, I've become more spiritual
and looking into just religion and just
spirituality in general.
>> Yeah. Now I was say raised Christian as
in my family or Christian. Um but I I
also uh I it was never something that I
that resonated with me even when I was a
kid. I never liked being in church and
nothing against the religion, it just
it's something that just never resonated
with me.
>> Um, and the second I was, you know, the
second I was given a choice to whether I
needed to come or not, if I wanted to
come or not, I was like, "Yeah, I'm not
coming anymore." And like I said, I was
very far away from spirituality.
>> You know, as I got older, leaning into
more spirituality, I've always had a lot
of Muslim friends being in living in
Edra Road originally, then moving to Har
Road, same thing. Like all the there's
Moroccans Lab all like I know and I've
always been a person that is I'm friends
with everybody. I mean I was cool with
everybody.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> So I get to experience even when I was
in I used to go to primary school. It's
called Gateway School and
>> I know Gateway.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I used to go primary
school there.
>> Y when it was Eid
>> Yeah.
>> Everyone disappeared. It was probably me
and two other kids. So like I've always
been in around it.
>> Yeah.
>> But again as I became more spiritual it
something about Islam resonated with me.
uh the discipline, the uh family kind of
I'm a very family orientated person.
>> Yeah. The
the just the the there's a certain
certain love and there's just a certain
energy that was drawn to
>> and then I I met my now beautiful wife
>> as well. Um she's come from Muslim
background. Um, so again, we just have
conversations about stuff
>> and I always say it's it wasn't to do
with her. She was always and she what
what I loved is she's like I would you
know if you was Muslim it would help
>> she was
but she's she's like look she loved me
for me. Yeah. It wasn't you know and I
said I I will never be forced into
anything. You know if if I come to this
place it's because I have decided to be
there. And to be fair, it surprised her
even when I said it cuz when I make my
mind up, I'm I'm like, "Yeah, okay. I
know."
>> Yeah.
>> And for me, I don't I can't even tell
you there was if there was a specific
moment.
>> I would just like, "Yeah, I know."
>> And and I want to do this.
>> Um, and I always say I I don't like to
use other people's experiences as
inspiration as to to to to make my
decisions. And simply because we don't
know where life takes us. So if I'm
inspired by a specific figure and it's
always good to have inspirations in
different ways, but if I'm inspired by a
different figure and something goes
wrong in their life
>> and I'm like, well, where does that
leave me now? No, I have to find this
myself. So for me, the energy and
everything had to come from my own
understandings. And I started doing more
research into into things and learning.
Um, and I'm like, it's just a it's just
a beautiful religion. There were still
things even I I was saying to my wife
there still things I was questioning
like I wasn't sure about but still there
were it's undeniable beauty in Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> I'll exchange details with you. Any
questions? We'll do research.
>> I've been I've been saying a long time
when I see him I was like I need to
reach out cuz I know your style.
>> When I saw it I was very very happy.
Thank you man.
>> For more for more reasons than one.
Obviously I've known you growing up.
>> So it's different for me. It's like
>> Yeah. Alhamdulillah. I always knew that
you've got that energy that you could
>> Yeah. He was any day, but many people
say that as well. Yeah. Like I've always
everyone like even my father-in-law used
to say like you've got you carry
yourself as if you're a Muslim.
>> Yes.
>> And um but yeah, I just it would just it
was just the right time. And it's weird
because as soon as I reverted, it's
everything just lined up like
um you know finding my wife getting
married. My first fight being um what at
that time there directly after in Saudi
>> then I went to Umrah.
>> Oh everything.
>> How did you find Omra?
>> Beautiful man. He liked it. And it's
it's just it's a
even when I speak to people that are not
religious, yeah, I say to them, can you
think about it? There's however many
millions of us around the world
>> or all or putting our energy into the
same directions.
>> Of course, it's going to be a magical
place. It's amazing, isn't it? Of
course. There's people from all over the
place. I mean um Malcolm X when he wrote
his auto he had this whole chapter
dedicated to going to Hajj actually and
he was talking about how that changed
him and how he saw everyone from all
play different places and stuff and all
worshiping one god
>> it's is a transform beautiful and then
also
>> one thing that um I find in Islam is
>> especially when we was down there
>> we everyone looks so different
>> but I have you go to certain maybe
certain Christian churches and one
pretty much the same. I just thought
Islam brings you get you're found from
anywhere. Allah finds you from all walks
of life. And it was beautiful to look
around and just see like so many shapes,
sizes, colors, all in the same place,
all know praying, worshiping together,
>> you know what I mean? There's a there's
a like I said, there's a family feel to
Islam and that's again something that
drew me through to being here.
>> Yeah. I was just talking to Aussie MMA.
I know you've done
and we spoke about the same thing and he
he was making some very good points. He
was saying look
>> even for fighting.
>> Yeah.
>> How when you when you have a belief in
one God and it's like okay this is the
most important thing.
>> Yeah.
>> And you believe in the the will of God.
>> So you're going in you've done all your
preparations but whatever happens is the
will of God. There's a liberation to
that.
>> 100%. Seriously there's a massive
liberation but also and I said to people
I was talking about this the other day.
You're never alone.
>> There's so many people that are
struggling with depression and and so
on, you know, just sadness, anxiety, but
you're never alone. And that's a
powerful thing. I could be no matter
what's going on in life, I have my faith
and Allah there with me to help me
through whatever time there is. And
there are people that are not religious
and they're they're there by themselves,
if you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Like they don't have
anybody to lean on, you know? I I've
been blessed with a big family and I
have support around me and love around
me. I know many don't have that. They
might just just have themselves but you
know being having a faith
>> and and revering over to Islam means
you're you're never by yourself.
>> Absolutely bro you're absolutely right
because there's an epidemic now
loneliness esidemic. Wow. It's become I
think there's even a min a loneliness
minister like a person that's designed
for that for that role. But
>> having like you said having believing in
one God
>> that is with you all the time in his
knowledge and his power is with them.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean taking that to the ring taking
that to your family taking that anywhere
else.
>> You're powerful anywhere. It's very
powerful.
>> It's very it's very powerful any and
everywhere. like doesn't matter what
you're doing as and I agree with what
you said in terms of I've done all the
preparation everything that I feel like
I can do I don't feel like I can do
anything more
I get to the I get to that cage and it's
it's the will of God yeah if it's
supposed to be inshallah you know my
hand will be raised
>> yeah because no one can predict like you
know you can do everything and then
something can happen on the day
something you don't know
>> exactly
>> but knowing that you tried your best
>> but then Allah subhana wa ta'ala God
almighty has a has a in The reciter
before we started he he read out a verse
and part of it was
which is that the affair of God is all
it's all written it's a plan yeah and so
having that belief I genuinely believe
that I mean in fact there are studies
about this study that I looked into in
2018 one that was done in Germany
>> by a woman called Laura Tobin and she
was saying that people who believe in
oneness beliefs
>> having and in fact they mentioned
Muslims they Muslims who believe inhed
or monotheism one God
>> that they have a higher satisfaction in
life because of that belief if in fact I
had a conversation with a guy called
Jordan Peterson now he's gone sorry to
say the wrong path because the politics
change he is he's an amazing I've
listened to him a lot so yeah
>> I had a conversation with him though
long time ago before he declared his
political stances yeah and I put this to
him I said to him look you know Um the
Quran says
that certain you the remembrance of God
do hearts find rest
and the Quran also mentions that
whoever averts his attention from my
remembrance he'll be depressed. So in
other words depression if you don't
believe in God if you don't worship in
God then you'll be depressed.
>> And even he agreed. He said look the
reason for that and he gave a reason. He
said is because your focus is
multiplicitus. If you are somebody who
is um who believes in many different
things, who relies on many different
things, then you become more anxious.
But if you have one focus, which is that
the worship of one God, which is a
transcendental thing,
>> if you believe in that, it's much more
powerful than than relying on other
things. So I think that now when you as
a Muslim
>> having that faith psychologically, it'll
put you in a much more powerful
position. Well, win or lose, it's a much
more power.
>> And that and I genuinely feel that like
genuinely feel that and people have said
to me even when I've lost fights.
>> Yeah. So, oh, you know, you can't
conduct yourself really really well. And
it's because I believe there's a plan.
There's I've had opponents that have
beaten me and you can't see them now.
>> Who would you say have been the most
difficult opponents that you faced
>> um
>> in your career?
>> Well, I'll say the the main one
obviously I lost via knockout uh to
Douglas Le.
>> That was more of a fluke, I would say.
He go like a kick.
>> But I always knew even even after the
the loss immediately I always knew that
I have the ability to beat this person.
It wasn't there was never a doubt in my
mind. It's like yeah you were the better
man tonight.
>> Yeah.
>> And I just got to stay steady on my path
>> and I'll find you again.
>> It was more of like a mistake that you
made.
>> Yeah. Yeah. 100. So there was load
there's there's again loads of variables
when it comes to fighting and
>> at that top level that's what I mean. No
matter where you are at that top level
it's a game of inches man. You mean one
mistake and it can be a detrimental
mistake and which is why we train so
hard to alleviate or you know make as
few mistakes as possible.
>> Um
>> apart from Douglas who else would you
put up there with the most difficult
fights you
>> uh again Story I'd say is a more
frustrating. So there's a different kind
of wrestling and stuff like that.
>> Yeah, he he he tried to play it safe. Um
and I think a lot of people do as well
which is why you know there's been a few
adjustments to the rules. There's I
don't mind people I don't mind people
wrestling. It's part of the game. Yeah.
>> But when you wrestle to just count the
the the clock down, you know, and in
hope that when you stand up, you know,
you get your hand raised, that's not a
fight.
>> Yeah.
>> If you you should be coming in there,
your wrestling should be you should be
getting me into a certain position,
beating me out as in part of our game.
>> Yeah.
>> So, when you're just wrestling for
wrestling sake, just to hold
>> is what I find it more frustrating.
That's more of like um I would say a
scorecard or what would you call
>> say? Yeah. And again, I feel like you're
not really doing the the sport justice.
>> Like again, we're here to see who the
better man is. It's not who can hold the
tightest. You're always the longest. But
nothing against wrestlers. I just like
Khabib.
>> Yeah.
>> He's an exceptional wrestler that tries
to continue inflict damage and win the
fight. It's not just wrestling. He
really is trying to beat you as well.
>> But somebody like that 100% that's fine.
But if after 15 minutes or 25 minutes I
stand up and I have I look the same and
you you get your hand raised. I don't
like that.
>> Yeah. You know,
>> but was it Ian Garry? His name was
>> Ian Garry was to be fair for me
personally there was a lot I'm not going
to go into it now. There's a lot
happened before. This is the one thing
that we we always forget that in the
buildup to a fight. There's so much that
could go on that you'll never see.
>> But I just wasn't the best me on the
day. So it is that was more frustrating.
It wasn't difficult. I don't find him a
difficult fighter at all.
>> I was just I just wasn't in the best
place I could have been in the in the
prep in the prep for that fight.
>> Yeah. Would you want to you want to
fight him again?
>> Yeah, I'd love to. I'd love to. And
again that um the reason I've moved up a
lot of people keep asking me cuz you
know like I said I'm a natural
welterweight. The welterweight division
is very political.
>> Really? Very very political. I don't
care. Meaning finding what? meaning
everybody's like people don't want to
fight this person or that person this
but it's very and as you've seen I've
got second I got to UFC I'm like big
names big names big names big names I
just want big and exciting fights I'm
not going to be in it for too much
longer I'm here to really just make a
big last push a big statement I want the
belt in the belt I want the belt in um
>> what middleweight or welterweight
>> I don't care anymore if if the
welterweight the guys are going to keep
arguing amongst themselves and not
fighting I'll leave them to it and I'll
do it at the middleweight
>> well let me ask this then because I mean
this since you brought it up you got DDP
and Hamza.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's play the game. Okay. Imagine Hamza
twins. Imagine DDP wins.
>> What would be how do you think that if
you were matched up with either of those
men, how would you again? It's a
difficult battle, but I'm here for those
exciting fights. It means
>> I I probably wouldn't have made it today
because I'd still be training.
You know what I mean? Like it's a it's
going to be one of those kind of fights
that means I have to put everything in
it. And again, Allah, if he's if if he
wants me to to win, inshallah, my hand
will be raised at the end of that. And
you know, I'm representing everybody
here.
>> Inshallah. Yeah. And we we're back at
you. Are we not?
>> You got a new fan base now. Thank you.
>> Got a Muslim fan base.
>> And I you know, and I felt that one
thing I have to say, I felt that again,
I did it for my own purposes, but then I
didn't realize what it would mean for
everybody else as well watching. And
there's been a lot of love. So I want to
thank everybody that has you know given
me love, supported me and I hopefully
continue supporting me inshallah. Um and
like I said I hope I can do you proud.
>> Oh you you've already done that brother.
>> Thank you bro. Thank you. Thank you so
much bro.
>> Thank you so much.
>> We'll send you details on the channel.
Questions anything you need let us amaz.
>> Thank you guys. Thank you. Thank you.
[Music]